Well, guys, congratulations.
The two of you are joining us
in the third and final round
of this competition.
In this final round,
we're sending you back
to your home forges
for four days
to build an iconic
weapon from history.
You're going to
be building this.
Bladesmiths, this
is the Naga sword.
[chuckles]
NARRATOR: The Naga
sword traces its origins
back to 16th century India.
Featuring a broad
square-chisel tip,
this weapon was
great at inflicting
powerful deadly chops in combat.
This rare version
of the Dao sword
was reserved for
the highest level
tribal authorities due to the
scarcity of iron in the area.
While few Naga
swords still exist,
it can be seen on display in
the halls of the British Museum
in London.
Good luck.
We'll see you in four days.
Let's get it.
My name's Chris Smith.
I'm 41 years old from
Bergen, Kentucky.
I am a refractory brick mason
and a part-time bladesmith.
I thoroughly enjoy
making knives.
It's a lot like a rabbit hole.
There's new materials coming
out all the time, new tools.
And I just enjoy the challenge.
It feels pretty good.
Got all the parameters met.
It's time to heat
treat this thing.
Let's hope this goes well.
There was no crazy
fireballs or broken
blades or anything like that.
The quench went great.
Yeah, it's hard.
I am stoked.
This thing is going
to look awesome.
I got it ground and
ready for etching.
It's going to look good.
[whistles]
The blade etched amazing.
It's time to start
thinking about the handle
and how I'm going to make it.
I feel like I have
plenty of time.
I'm doing some research
online about this Naga sword.
The majority that I saw had
red goat hair off the pommel,
just as a decoration.
So I ordered goat
hair off the internet.
I think it's perfect.
[music playing]
I'm Joseph, JoJo, Salyers.
I am 19 years old from
Rutherfordton, North Carolina.
I'm a full-time
bladesmith with my dad,
Billy Salyers, who
just so happens to be
a Forged in Fire champion.
Billy, you are the
Forged in Fire champion.
Good job, brother.
And so here I am hoping
I can show the old man up.
Well, it's coming
along pretty well.
We've got a solid
build in Damascus.
It's time to get my
blade in the oil.
With Damascus, you have
a bunch of little welds.
Any of those welds
could possibly pop open.
I'm hoping everything
comes out all good.
All right, hot metal.
My sword's quenched.
It's pretty straight.
All in all, my
blade's mostly done.
Most of the work I have to do
is aesthetics and sharpening.
That is what you like to see.
My dad was kind
enough to give me
something to test my blade on.
I present you a challenge
worthy of your skills.
[laughing]
Finally, a worthy opponent.
[music playing]
Yeah.
It shall go on the wall
and we shall stuff it.
My sword's comfy, sharp.
It's done.
Now it's time to go see what
the judges can do with it.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapons will do,
I'm going to take your weapons
and put some lethal blows
or chops on this pig carcass.
JoJo, are you ready for this?
Let's make some pork chops.
[laughing]
You got it.
[music playing]
All right, JoJo, pork
chops you wanted.
Pork chops you got.
Most of the weight is
right here in the handle.
So that really lends itself
to a nice balanced weapon.
Your sword's edge over here
chops deeply, especially
on that one swing on the leg.
And overall, it'll kill.
Awesome.
All right, Chris,
your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
- Yes, sir.
All right, let's do this.
[music playing]
That's what I'm talking about.
All right, Chris.
The first thing I
notice about this
is just how sharp
your edge is ground.
And that lends itself
for very deep cuts.
And I like the throwback to the
'90s troll hair right there.
But overall, sir, your
Naga sword, it will kill.
Thank you, sir.
All right, gentlemen,
welcome to the strength
test, the howdah chop.
Now, those howdahs would be
riding on top of an elephant.
But this test is not
about what your Naga
swords do to the howdah,
but what that howdah
does to your blades.
And, JoJo, you are up first.
You ready?
I suppose so.
[music playing]
All right, so JoJo,
there's no damage.
It's a kind of an ax grind, but
on a chopper, it works fine.
It held up beautifully
in the strength test.
Well done.
Thank you.
Chris, you ready to
play with the howdah?
Yes, sir.
All right.
[music playing]
Chris, I'm going to start
back here on your handle.
I like this.
It's got a fairly
traditional look to it.
As far as your blade goes, we
have a little bit of an issue.
Your edge has deflected over to
one side, but it's still sharp.
Other than that, I think
you did a good job.
Well done.
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the sharpness test,
the jackfruit and rope slice.
JoJo, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Absolutely.
All right.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, JoJo, your edge
cut nicely on these jackfruits
and the rope.
Overall, it will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Chris,
your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
- Yes, sir.
All right.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Chris, so in
cutting the jackfruit,
this section right here
met the jackfruits.
So that includes this area
that took some damage.
You can feel a little bit of
a drag, but it did not affect.
It was able to cut through
the jackfruit and the rope.
Overall, sir, your
weapon, it will cut.
Thank you.
Well, bladesmiths, both
your blades tested well,
but only one of you can go home
with a Forged in Fire champion
title and a check for $10,000.
Our judges have
discussed your blades,
and they made a final decision.
Today's Forged in
Fire champion is--
JoJo.
Congratulations.
Chris, there's no
doubting you are
an extremely talented smith.
But unfortunately, your time
in this competition has ended.
I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off the Forge floor.
- All right.
Thank you all for having me.
Thank you, Chris.
It's a beautiful piece.
Awesome, brother.
Thanks, mate.
Take care, guys.
I think it all came down to
the heat treatment on my blade.
I'm not sure what went wrong,
but something obviously did.
JoJo, congratulations.
That means you are the newest
Forged in Fire champion.
Not only that, you are
the very first father
and son champion
that's ever come
through Forged in Fire, man.
Congratulations.
[applause]
I cannot wait to
get home and tell Dad.
This is going to be super
cool, and he's going
to be just as excited as I am.
Is this a blade
you'll build again?
I think I'll
make an extra one.
I need something to
show off at the house.
[laughter]
This is so awesome.
I never thought I'd be here.
And, man, it's just a blessing.
JoJo's the Forged
in Fire champion.
Let's go.
Up top.
Yeah.
[music playing]